[Music]
you know I don't want to get I don't
want to hurt I'm I love you so much
we're not new oh I didn't you at the
right house the other night I know you
were there but I didn't see you at all
it was crazy it was a big round more
than a few I can't kiss you properly is
your husband here - he's gonna be sad
your husband conversation anything with
the microphone right but the two of you
together I'm kind of feeling like I
needed to like step back you're look so
gorgeous
I heard time he was perfect wasn't it I
know they just got you out of having to
answer me didn't it typically oh well
time I think she wants to know if
there's gonna be another Sex in the City
movie but does she gonna be another Sex
in the City movie wait one minute yeah
don't call divorce but even I swear I
know it's a good show it's amazing she's
like can we talk about that which we did
divorces I didn't ignore that we didn't
talk about that I know in securing
divorce got me through my maternity
leave
absolutely I've heard about the baby
we have a mutual friend I hope you guys
are at the same table shares
I think they'll separate us you can see
why too good I love it wait just one
final question who took longer to get
ready tonight come on early so that it
was a pleasant experience and not rushed
and since I don't have any children with
me here which is different I pumping
time how many how many hours with the
pumping how many hours like an epic
journey through time yeah if I admitted
the amount of hours I would never be
able to look in the mirror tomorrow okay
you have an excuse if you're pumping in
between yes yeah and you were enjoying
so you have a reason yeah I sort of
enjoyed it we weren't you know there was
a pace that was really Pleasant and I
ate in between and my friend was there
and visited like she has in the past you
know I read a little bit I think you
guys you got your ears
Oh like sort of apparition is that what
it was I got wound you guys need to be
on each other show like this look like I
just want you know I'm taking full on
credit if you guys wind up on each other
show okay I'm gonna give you something
great they're gonna use all this are you
getting yeah congratulations thank you
thank you Sarah Jessica all kinds of
reporters going on it was awesome are
you kidding my best moment number one